[Música]
economía en directo américa france24 ya
está conmigo nuevamente en el estudio
daniela blandón daniela para hablar de
grecia que comenzó la construcción de
una terminal de gas licuado de petróleo
no esto también para paliar pues el
suministro que recibían desde rusia
claro que sí y raúl adivino
pues mire lo que busca agradecía es
justamente como ustedes lo decía mejorar
ese suministro hacia el sureste de
europa y así reducir la dependencia de
rusia y es que entre grecia y alemania
están hoy por ahí sirviendo de enlace
para llevar gas a polonia y a bulgaria
después de que rusia cerrará el grifo
por su negativa a pagar en rublos por
eso la unión europea sigue diseñando un
sexto paquete de sanciones contra rusia
que podría incluir un posible embargo
sobre la compra de petróleo petróleo no
gas hay que aclarar eso alemania dice
que pues que ellos ellos serán de los
que más se oponían portugal por su alta
dependencia pero ahora ya cambió de
opinión pero eslovaquia y hungría creen
que no se pueden dar ese lujo porque lo
que están pidiendo es una excepción con
ellos dependen bastante
la comisión europea dice que está en
esta etapa no existe un riesgo inmediato
para la seguridad energética de la
región y muestra de ello son justamente
estos nuevos proyectos que se están
adelantando
programa álbum este programa
muestra nuestra disposición a responder
a los desafíos del presente asegurando
nuevas rutas de suministro que evitan a
terceros países que no están dispuestos
a cooperar escribe tus moscas esquís y
metro los recientes chantajes de moscú
sobre el gas natural hacen que esta
cooperación no sólo sea necesaria sino
urgente al hacer de la chica te puso
daniel y también hoy inicia la reunión
mensual de la reserva federal de eeuu le
pregunto que se espera bueno aunque los
resultados se esperan para este
miércoles porque la reunión de dos días
y todo el mercado ya apunta a que habrá
una subida de tasas de interés incluso
mayor a la que hubo en la pasada reunión
y eso hará que sea más costoso desde
pedir un préstamo para un automóvil
hasta una casa o una simple compra con
tarjeta de crédito y también puede
enfriar una economía que está al rojo
vivo los analistas están casi seguros de
que el aumento será de 50 puntos básicos
y de esta manera los tipos de interés
quedarían en un rango de entre el 0 75 y
el 1 por ciento esto sigue siendo bajo
si se compara con otros países del
continente como por ejemplo colon en
donde los más recientes aumentos han
duplicado la tasa de interés únicamente
en los cuatro meses que van corridos del
año en diciembre esa tasa era del 3% hoy
estamos en 6% aragón y sigo también
adivinando porque seguramente estas
tasas de interés van a ser el plato
fuerte de esa semana sí o no claro que
sí adivino también raúl este jueves
habrá reunión de los bancos centrales de
chile también de inglaterra entre
bastantes otros y las reuniones que ya
se han llevado a cabo dejan sorpresas
primero fue suecia ahora es australia
los bancos centrales que habían dicho
que no veían la necesidad de subir las
tasas hasta 2023 o 2024 pues se
arrepintieron y lo hicieron en el caso
de australia la primera vez en 11 años
y los hogares tienen mucha más deuda que
antes y muchos de ellos nunca han
experimentado un aumento en el interés
por lo tanto este es otro aspecto que
estamos observando muy de cerca en los
próximos meses no pueden empezar de esas
incertidumbres espero que sean
necesarios más aumentos en las tasas de
interés en los próximos meses entonces
tenían de todo esto cómo está
reaccionando el mercado pues mire las
bolsas operan mixtas y con muy leves
variaciones con los ojos desde luego
puestos en wall street estos dos días de
reunión de la fed los principales
índices de referencia subieron en hong
kong en parís y en francfort pero
cayeron en sydney y en londres pero muy
poquito porque el mercado está muy
pendiente de las tasas así es y vamos a
chile venimos a nuestra región de
suramérica donde en ese país comenzaron
a discutir un aumento de salario claro
que si fue promesa de campaña del
presidente gabriel bordi si la propuesta
ya llegó al parlamento chileno para su
discusión en ambas cámaras esta
iniciativa consiste en subir
gradualmente el salario mínimo mensual
en 14,3 por ciento desde los actuales
305 en pesos que son unos
450 o unos 405 dólares
el alza entonces lo llevaría a 380 mil
pesos entre mayo y agosto y a 400.000 de
ahí en adelante lo que equivale a unos
460 dólares al cambio de hoy y el
ejecutivo hizo otra promesa dijo que si
en diciembre la inflación acumulada
superaba al 7% iba a promover un nuevo
aumento esta vez a 410 mil pesos o unos
475 dólares y para que vayan haciendo
las cuentas esa inflación hoy es del 9,4
por cien como 4 por ciento vamos a ver
qué nos espera nosotros aquí en colombia
mientras tanto repreguntó la cifra del
día 62 por ciento de los trabajadores de
una planta de servicios de amazon en
nuevayork votó en contra de crear un
sindicato un mes antes otro centro de
distribución que queda justo al frente
había votado a favor y se convirtió en
la primera organización sindical del
segundo mayor empleador de eeuu dale
gracias como siempre por toda la
información nos vamos directamente hasta
parís eric olavarría ya está lista para
hablarnos de toda la actualidad francesa